problema número 148 cuales el menor
entero que es la suma de tres números
primos diferentes cada uno mayor que 20
y esencialmente lo que tenemos que hacer
es encontrar los tres números primos más
pequeños que sean mayores que 20 20 no
es primo 21
tampoco 23 3 es primo lo escribimos 23
en 24 no lo es 25 tampoco 26 no a 27
tampoco 28 no lo es 29 si es número
primo 29
y 30/30 no es primo pero 31 si lo es
aquí tenemos estos tres números primos
que son los más chicos que hay que son
mayores que 20 y nos piden que los
sumemos el 23 más 29 es igual a 252 52
más 31 es igual a 83 y esta es mi opción
siguiente problema número 149 el
promedio de 68 y 10 es igual al promedio
de 79 y x
hay que encontrar x hagamos el promedio
de 6
8 y 10 que suman estas cantidades y
dividirla entre el número de cantidades
que en este caso es 3 esto es 18 + 6
esto es igual a 24 tercios 24 entre 3 es
igual a 8 esto es igual al promedio de
79 y x esto es igual al promedio de 7 es
decir 7 + 9 + x entre 3 a ambos lados de
esta ecuación por 3 y nos queda 8 por 3
24 igual a esta parte 9 7 es 16 x + 16
restamos 16 en ambos lados y nos queda
que x es igual a 24 menos 16 x es igual
a 8 que es la opción c
y esto quizás lo podemos haber deducido
viendo el promedio de este estos números
que es 8 y si era el mismo pues bueno el
único valor que aquí cabrían para hacer
este mismo promedio pues es el 8 aquí en
medio de entre el 7 y el 9 pero bueno lo
hicimos de esta manera veamos el
siguiente problema en cuenta si x es
igual a menos 1 que será igual
- x cúbica más x cuadrada entre x menos
1 veamos
menos 1 al cuarto va a ser igual a uno
menos x
- que es menos 1 - 1 al cubo este va a
ser un menos uno
x cuadrada x menos 1 - 1 al cuadrado
menos 1 al cuadrado va a ser igual a 1 o
menos se hace más y me queda uno más uno
más uno eso es sólo del numerador ahora
del denominador uno menos uno va a ser
igual a menos dos igual a menos tres
medios
que es mi opción
muy bien siguiente problemas una tienda
de juguetes por lo regular vende su
existencia con un descuento del 20 al
40% si se rebaja un 25% adicional al
precio con descuento cuál será el menor
precio posible de un juguete que cuesta
16 antes de cualquier descuento
entonces nos dicen que el descuento va
del 20 al 40% para encontrar el mayor
descuento vamos a usar el 40% el costo
de juguete es de 16 hay qué número
canción 16 y lo queremos multiplicar por
la cantidad que va a representar el
precio ya aplicado el descuento y vamos
a trabajar con fracciones creo que las
fracciones son un poquito más fáciles de
manejar aquí
cuando esta infracción el resto del 40
por ciento es decir el 60 por ciento que
si se va a pagar de este precio como lo
represento en fracción pues lo voy a
representar como 3 puntos 16 por tres
quintos
tengo que agregarle un 25% de descuento
adicional para ver el precio que voy a
pagar ya una vez aplicado este 25% de
descuento en fracción el resto el
complemento este 25% es decir el 75% que
si voy a pagar está representado en
fracción como tres cuartos por tres
cuartos y ahora si voy a operar todo
esto de entrada 16 entre 4 esto lo puedo
quitar me queda aquí 4 me queda aquí 14
por 3 por 3 3 por 4 12 por 3 es igual a
5 por unas 5 36 puntos que esto es igual
a 7 enteros un quinto que esto lo puedo
expresar como 7.20 ese es el costo del
juguete ya con todos los descuentos
aplicados y es mi opción b
siguiente problema nos muestran esta
figura y nos dicen que la parte
sombreada de este rectángulo tiene un
área de 24 metros cuadrados aquí esto
mide 24
uno de sus lados vamos a decir que este
es x y vale de 2
y el otro lado me de que esto de aquí y
de aquí acá
y de aquí acá y nos preguntan cuál es el
valor de z
este z la hipotenusa de este triángulo
bueno si el área es 24 quiere decir que
la fórmula de área de este triángulo que
es base por altura entre 2 va a ser
igual a 24 la base es nos ponemos un
medio de x x es igual a 24 y podemos
multiplicar ambos lados por 2 nos queda
por x es igual a 48 y ahora vamos a
sustituir nos dicen que x es igual a más
2 voy a sustituir esto aquí en xy me
queda que james x + 2
es igual a 48 desarrollo esto porque
cuadrada
+ 2 por qué
igual a 48 y eso lo puedo expresar
también como de cuadrada más 12 menos 48
igual a 0 y ahora la tengo en formato de
ecuación cuadrática vamos a factorizar
esta ecuación en números al multiplicar
se dan menos 48 y sumados dan dos
positivos bueno pues aquí puede tener de
más 8 x y menos 6 menos 6 por 8 es menos
48 y 8 menos 6 es 2 así que estas son
soluciones para esta ecuación por lo
tanto me puede tener el valor de menos 8
el valor de 6 pero como estamos hablando
de distancias pues no hay distancias
negativas este no puede ser así que mi
valor de y es 6
esto vale 6 y si esto vale 6 este x que
es más 2 va a valer 6 más 28 ahora con
todos estos valores y con el teorema de
pitágoras puedo encontrar el valor de z
el teorema nos dice que el cuadrado de
los catetos la suma del cuadrado de los
catetos 6 x 6 36 más 8 x 8 64 es igual a
el cuadrado de la hipotenusa que en este
caso es set al cuadrado sumamos esto
esto es 100 igual a z al cuadrado
y nuestro acepta qué es lo que nos
interesa va a ser igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 100
y la raíz cuadrada de 100 es 10 10 por
y esta es mi opción
muy bien siguiente problema leo en este
momento es mayor que memo por 14 años si
en 10 años leo tendrá el doble de edad
que memo qué edad tendrá leo en cinco
años
anotemos los datos leo en este momento
es tiene la edad de memo más 14 años
y nos dicen que leo dentro de 10 años a
esta edad más 10 va a ser igual al doble
de la edad de memo pero memo también
pues después de 10 años va a tener esta
edad más 10 años así que es que me más
10 nos preguntan la edad de león +5 qué
cantidad sera
bueno vamos a despejar la m de aquí
vamos a dejar en términos de la edad de
memo es igual a la edad de leo menos 14
y vamos a situarlo acá
y la edad que tiene más 10 años es igual
al doble de la edad de memo pero nada de
memo ahorita es de l menos 14 esto más
simplificamos bueno distribuimos esto me
queda que 10 menos 14 es menos cuatro
elementos 42 por el menos cuatro está el
10 vamos a distribuir esto nos queda que
es 2 l menos 2 por 4 8
el 10 vamos a restar l en ambos lados de
esta ecuación nos va a quedar que 10 es
igual a l menos 2 l pues va a quedar el
menos ocho sumamos ocho en ambos lados
nos va a quedar que
18 leo él es igual a 18 que esta es la
edad que tienen leo actualmente
18 años y nos preguntan cuál será su
edad dentro de 5 años pues a esto nada
más le agregamos 5 años por lo que la
edad de leo va 5 años es igual a 18 más
5 va a ser igual a 23 años que es
nuestra opción d
con eso terminamos los problemas de este
vídeo y nos vemos en el siguiente